SOUTH AFRICA.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST TO
TREAT PATIENTS WITH THE OMICRON.
SHE IS CHAIR OF THE SOUTH
AFRICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
DOCTOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US.
I KNOW YOU WERE JUST TREATING
OTHER PATIENTS, SO WE APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING THE TIME TO SPEAK TO
US.
WE HAVE VERY IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
FOR YOU.
NAMELY, TALK TO US ABOUT THE
SEVERITY OF THE CASES YOU ARE
SEEING.
HOW SICK ARE THE PATIENTS YOU
ARE SEEING WHO DO HAVE THIS NEW
VARIANT?
>> GOOD EVENING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON.
SOUTH AFRICA TIME, IT IS
SO, YEAH, IT IS A VERY GOOD
QUESTION.
THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE CURRENTLY ARE SEEING.
IT IS VERY EARLY DAYS, AND IT IS
NOW, MORE OR LESS, I CALL IT
A -- WE HAVE MADE A DIAGNOSIS OF
THE NEW VARIANT GOING AROUND.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE BEGINNING OF
ANY PANDEMIC WAVE, IT IS
NORMALLY NOT THAT SEVERE.
IT IS NORMALLY THE YOUNGER
PEOPLE THAT GET INFECTED.
FROM THERE ON, IT'LL SPREAD AND
GO FURTHER.
SO, HOPEFULLY, WE CAN KEEP THE
CLINICAL PICTURE AS IT IS.
IF WE SAY PATIENTS ARE NOT --
THEY'RE MODERATELY ILL, NOT
SEVERELY ILL.
I'M ALSO A PART OF A GROUP OF
EIGHT DOCTORS, SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES, ONLY TWO PATIENTS
WERE ADMITTED IN THE LAST 24
HOURS, AND I'M NOT SURE OF THEIR
SYMPTOMS.
WHAT WE ARE PRESENTING TO
PRIMARY HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONERS IS MILD CASES,
MILD TO MODERATE.
SO THESE PATIENTS, THEY DON'T
NEED TO BE HOSPITALIZED FOR NOW.
AND WE TRY TO GET THE MESSAGE
OUT THERE TO THE WORLD TO SAY,
LISTEN, WE'RE NOT SAYING THIS IS
NOT GOING TO BE A DISEASE GOING
FORWARD THAT'S GOING TO CAUSE
SEVERE DISEASE.
IT WILL CAUSE SEVERE DISEASE.
BUT IF WE CAN GET THIS -- IF
THIS DISEASE CAN POSE TO THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE MILD
SYMPTOMS, EASILY TREATED AT
HOME, NO NEED FOR ADMISSION,
THAT'S THE FIRST PRIZE.
BUT FOR US TO TELL THIS TO THE
WORLD, WE NEED TO TELL YOU WHAT
THE SYMPTOMS ARE SO THAT THE
PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND.
IF I FEEL FATIGUED FOR A DAY OR
TWO, NOT THE FATIGUE YOU'RE USED
TO.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT FATIGUE.
A BIT OF A SCRATCHY THROAT, BODY
ACHE AND PAIN, AND A HEADACHE.
WE CALL IT MALAISE, SO I DON'T
FEEL GENERALLY WELL.
GO SEE YOUR DOCTOR.
WE NEED TO TELL THE DOCTORS,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SEE A VERY
SICK PATIENT SITTING IN FRONT OF
YOU.
TEST THE PATIENT.
IF YOU CAN TEST AND TRACE, AND
WE CAN GET THE PATIENTS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS MILD
SYMPTOMS FOR NOW, BUT GO AND SEE
A HEALTH CARE FACILITY.
GO AND GET YOURSELF CHECKED OUT.
IF YOU CAN GET THAT MESSAGE OUT
TO THE WORLD, IT MEANS THAT WE
WOULD MOST PROBABLY, GOING
FORWARD, HAVE LESS SEVERE CASES,
LESS PEOPLE GOING TO THE
DOCTOR'S.
NO SYSTEM CAN AFFORD THAT.
NOT SOUTH AFRICA.
NOT THE UNITED STATES.
NO ONE CAN AFFORD THAT.
>> LET ME JUST REITERATE, IF I
CAN, DOCTOR, AND JUMP IN HERE,
JUST TO REITERATE ONE POINT SO
PEOPLE HEAR IT CLEARLY.
THIS CAN CHANGE, AND I
UNDERSTAND IT'S THE EARLY
STAGES, BUT RIGHT NOW, PATIENTS
WITH THIS NEW VARIANT, YOU'RE
DEALING WITH MILD TO MODERATE
SYMPTOMS?
YOU ARE SEEING NO OR VERY LITTLE
SEVERE DISEASE, CORRECT?
>> YES.
>> HAVE YOU TREATED PATIENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN VACCINATED AND NOW ARE
COMING IN --
>> YES, I HAVE.
>> -- WITH THE NEW VARIANT?
>> YES.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SEEING THERE?
>> SAME PICTURE.
INTERESTING ENOUGH, WITH THE
MODERATE -- WHAT WE CALL MILD,
YOU KNOW, SYMPTOMS, THE PATIENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN VACCINATED SO FAR
HAVE NO COMPLICATION.
THEY ARE -- I DON'T KNOW IT IS
AS IF IT IS -- I DON'T WANT TO
USE THE WORD SELF-LIMITING, BUT
MINIMUM CONSERVATIVE
MEASUREMENTS THAT THEY NEEDED,
AND THEY FEEL FINE.
IT SEEMS TO ME IT IS ABOUT THE
FIRST TWO DAYS BEFORE THEY COME
AND SEE THE DOCTOR.
IT IS ANOTHER THREE OR FOUR
DAYS, AND THEY'RE OUT OF IT.
SO THE NICE THING IS IF YOU PICK
IT UP, IF YOU MAKE THE DIAGNOSIS
AND YOU TAKE THE PATIENT OUT AND
GET THEM TO SELF-ISOLATE, GET
THE REST OF THE FAMILY TO
QUARANTINE, YOU WILL ALSO SPREAD
LESS.
YES, I HAVE SEEN VACCINATED
PEOPLE AND NOT REALLY VERY SICK.
THAT MIGHT CHANGE GOING FORWARD.
AS WE SAY, THIS IS EARLY DAYS.
AND THIS IS MAYBE WHAT MAKES US
HOPEFUL.
>> I DO UNDERSTAND THESE ARE
EARLY STAGES, BUT I ALSO THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING.
YOU ARE SEEING PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN INFECTED OR VACCINATED, AND
THEY'RE JUST NOT VERY SICK,
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU HOPE
FOR WITH THE VACCINE IN GENERAL.
>> YES.
>> WE DON'T KNOW OVER THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS AS THE TESTS COME BACK
IF MAYBE, MAYBE THE OMICRON WILL
FIND WAYS TO EVADE THE VACCINE.
AS OF NOW, IT DOES SEEM TO BE
OFFERING SOME PROTECTION.
THAT DOES SEEM TO BE KEY.
BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME,
WITH MILD TO MODERATE CASES,
WITH THE VACCINATED PEOPLE WHO
HAVE IT WITH VERY MILD CASES,
WHAT IS YOUR ASSESSMENT OF HOW
THE WORLD HAS REACTED TO THE
NEWS COMING OUT OF SOUTH AFRICA
ABOUT THE OMICRON VARIANT?
>> I THINK IT WAS AN
OVERREACTION.
I DO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF MUTATION IN THIS VIRUS.
I DO UNDERSTAND THAT IT MIGHT BE
MUCH MORE FAST SPREADING THAN
THE DELTA VARIANT.
BUT IF YOU LOOK -- YOU KNOW, I
THINK WHAT ONE NEEDS TO DO,
THERE'S TWO TYPES OF -- AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE MEDICAL
FIELD WILL UNDERSTAND BETTER
WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY.
SO YOU GET TWO TYPES.
YOU GET THE SCIENTISTS, AND WE
NEED THE SCIENTISTS.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THE
INPUT FROM THE SCIENTISTS.
BUT WHILE THE SCIENTISTS WAIT
AND ARE BUSY DOING THEIR WORK IN
THE BACKGROUND, UNFORTUNATELY,
THE PATIENTS DOESN'T WAIT.
THE PATIENTS COME IN.
YOU NEED TO ALERT YOUR DOCTORS,
THERE IS SOMETHING GOING ON.
LOOK AT IT.
SEE WHAT YOU CAN DO.
SO, YOU KNOW, THEN TELLING THE
WORLD THERE IS SOMETHING OUT
THERE AND THEN BEING SLAMMED BY
GETTING THESE, WE CALL IT THE
KNEE-JERK REACTION OF CLOSING
BORDERS, AND EVERYONE SAYING,
YES, BUT I'M TRYING TO PROTECT
MY PEOPLE.
SO THE QUESTION WOULD BE, HOW DO
YOU KNOW IT IS NOT IN YOUR
COUNTRY YET?
HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT A LOT OF
THOSE INFECTIONS THAT YOU ARE
CURRENTLY SEEING THAT IS SEVERE,
HOW DO YOU KNOW IT IS NOT MAYBE
RELATED TO THE OMICRON?
HOW DO YOU KNOW?
AND HOW DO THE DOCTORS KNOW IF
THEY'RE NOT AWARE THAT THE
PATIENT SITTING IN FRONT OF THEM
WITH A BIT OF A SCRATCHY THROAT
AND SAYS, "OH, DON'T FEEL QUITE
WELL, DOCTOR," A BIT OF A FLU IS
WHAT THEY'D NORMALLY CALL IT.
IT'S NOT TOO BAD, AND THE DOCTOR
WOULD PRESCRIBE PAINKILLERS.
THEY WOULDN'T TEST BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT THINKING IT MIGHT BE
OMICRON.
FOR SOUTH AFRICA TO SPREAD THE
MESSAGE OUT THERE, AND THEN
BEING SLAMMED DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE.
OF COURSE, IT IS OTHER PEOPLE'S
LIVES AS WELL.
YOU KNOW, IT IS A HUGE IMPACT.
IT IS A HUGE IMPACT ON THE
ECONOMY OF SOUTH AFRICA.
IT IS A HUGE IMPACT TO THE
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO COME AND
VISIT FAMILY.
IT IS A HUGE IMPACT FROM SOUTH
AFRICANS THAT WANT TO VISIT
FAMILY AND FRIENDS DURING THE
FESTIVE SEASON.
I JUST THINK, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
OTHER WAYS TO DO THIS.
>> AGAIN, I WANT TO REITERATE,
AS YOU HAVE MANY TIMES, IT IS
EARLY AND WE STILL HAVE MUCH TO
LEARN.
BUT THE EPIDEMIOLOGY, WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE HISTORY OF
PANDEMICS OR VIRUSES, THERE HAS
BEEN A TENDENCY FOR MUTATIONS
TOWARD THE MORE MILD.
THERE HAVE BEEN VIRUSES, AND
THERE'S SCIENTIFIC REASONS FOR
IT, WHY WHEN THEY DO MUTATE,
THEY MUTATE TO BECOMING MORE
MILD.
YOU SAY IT IS POSSIBLE THAT IF
THAT'S WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH OMICRON, THAT IT MAY
CONTRIBUTE TO HERD IMMUNITY.
HOW WOULD THAT WORK?
>> WELL, I WOULD BE HAPPY IF
THAT WOULD BE THE CASE, BUT ONLY
TIME WILL TELL US.
HOPEFULLY THAT WOULD, YOU
KNOW -- WITH THIS FAST SPREADING
OF THE VIRUS, WITH PEOPLE BEING
VACCINATED, HOPEFULLY THIS WOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT WE CAN JUST
PRAY FOR GOING FORWARD.
IT'S NOT TO SAY IT IS NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN, BUT, AGAIN, YOU KNOW,
THE 30 PLUS MUTATIONS ARE
WORRISOME TO OUR SCIENTISTS.
ACTUALLY, THEY DON'T REALLY WANT
US TO SAY THAT THIS IS MILD AT
THIS STAGE.
BUT IT IS WHAT WE SEE.
WE CANNOT GO OUT THERE AND
ADVISE DOCTORS AND PEOPLE AND
SAY, "LISTEN, WAIT FOR THE
SYMPTOMS TO COME."
YOU NEED TO KNOW WHAT THE
SYMPTOMS IS WHILE WE WAIT TO SEE
HOW THIS VIRUS IS GOING TO
BEHAVE.
>> FATIGUE, SCRATCHY THROAT,
LOOK FOR THEM.
OVER THE NEXT TWO WEEKS, WHAT IS
THE BIGGEST QUESTION YOU WANT
ANSWERED?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE OVER THE
NEXT TWO WEEKS, THE BIGGEST
QUESTION WOULD BE IS IT GOING TO
GIVE US MORE SEVERE DISEASE?
WHAT IS IT GOING TO DO TO THE
ELDERLY THAT'S UNVACCINATED?
OR PEOPLE WITH CO-MORBIDITIES?
IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT
IT IS GOING TO DO.
THE SECOND THING THAT IS
IMPORTANT, WE NEED THE DOCTOR TO
SEE HOW MANY VACCINATED PEOPLE
GOT SEVERE INFECTIONS AND
BREAKTHROUGH INFECTIONS.
THEN THE THIRD AND LAST ONE
WOULD BE HOW MANY PEOPLE
PREVIOUSLY HAD COVID-1 AND GET
RE-INFECTED?
AGAIN, IS IT MILD OR SEVERE, TO
BE ADMITTED?
FROM A CLINICAL PERSPECTIVE,
THAT IS IMPORTANT.
DOES IT REALLY MATTER FOR ME
WHEN THE PATIENT SITTING IN
FRONT OF ME HAS 30 MUTATIONS OR
NOT?
I STILL NEED TO TREAT HIM
WHETHER IT IS 2 MUTATIONS, 30
MUTATIONS.
I NEED TO MAKE SURE I DO WHAT IS
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THIS
PATIENT.
SO FROM A CLINICIAN'S POINT OF